[Musique]
elijah a changé au fil des années il a
baissé les bras
nous lui administrant un sédatif
puissant mais il ya une raison à cela
il est trop brillant bourg bientôt tu ne
sera plus seul tu as deux nouveaux
copains
vous pensez tous les trois à avoir des
dons extraordinaires comme ceux qu'on
trouve dans les comics
j'ai mis au point un traitement efficace
contre cette pathologie sous l'effet des
flashs une nouvelle identité va faire
surface enfin bon signe rendez moi mais
tu écouteurs eloignez-vous de la terreur
très cher et super force la dette
vous n'avez pas l'intention de me
laisser sortir d'ici option en a marre
vous avez raison
que voulez vous je suis venu voir si
c'est vrai ce cours à côte sur ces êtres
pour dire
puis je rencontrais la bête je m'appelle
marie raynal
j'ai besoin de vos talents pour que nous
payons tous sortir d'ici et montrer au
monde entier que nous existants
on dirait bien que les méchants ont
décidé de faire équipe
croyez vous votre mission dans ce
penseur partenaires
oui profondément source
il faut que je sorte de cet hôpital
avant lui il n'y a aucun risque
il y a toujours un génie incompris dans
l'histoire
[Musique]
ça a commencé des vides j'ai trouvé
quelqu'un qui mobilisera tout votre
potentiel
vous ne devriez pas rester dans l'ombre
peut-être voudrez-vous nous faire
obstacle
[Musique]
beaucoup de gens vont mourir
alors qu'est ce que ça ferait plaisir un
sandwich au beurre de cacahuètes
nous ne sommes pas censés avoir un
pouvoir pareil
hop hop hop enfin nous sommes tous
réunis et le monde va voir de quoi nous
sommes capables
il faut vous sortiez de 6
[Musique]
mais qu'avez vous fait elijah